hi everyone we're very excited to be
here today and to talk to you about
unlocking genomic records on the cloud
part of why we decided to have this talk
is that the life sciences industry is
actually undergoing a monumental shift
in the way it works and cloud is
actually becoming central the way they
work and conduct research this talk is
specifically focused around genomics and
how technology is completely changing
fields like Diagnostics
and the development of new treatments
with the use of data
we'll start by providing an overview of
the landscape today and where we are
then we're gonna be talking about some
of the challenges with genomics and
we're gonna be talking about how cloud
can help solve these challenges and then
we're gonna be going through some
tooling and how to actually use some of
this genomics specific tooling on GCP
and finally we're gonna be showcasing a
demo of how to do that so my name is
Hussein Alma Scotty I work as a customer
engineer in Google Cloud primarily
focused on public sector and life
sciences and my name is Heather Noir I
also work as a customer engineered in
Google Cloud focus and life sciences we
are both based in London and are
presenting you to you today from our
humble homes as customer engineers we
work very closely with our customers to
help enable them to adopt and use Clark
and help them develop solutions that are
cloud based and our primary focus is
working with public institutions and
research organizations so take a cough
there's an interesting statement that
says there'll be a hundred sixty-three
zettabytes of data by 2025 I'll give you
a few seconds for you to actually absorb
the
so to give you some context that is
equivalent to watching a cat video that
is about twice as long as the universe
is old and to give you another way of
looking at it all the data that has been
generated by mankind up to the 1980s is
less than a zettabyte so that means the
majority of this data is actually net
new so where is all this data coming
from well I mean part of it is from you
taking pictures uploading them videos
etc but a big part of it is actually
from health care and life sciences
medical imaging is actually number one
but genomics is not that far from it and
the amount of genomics day that is
actually exponentially growing and
resulting in a huge challenge in terms
of how we can handle it and manage this
data this growth means that there needs
to be like a new medium or way of
handling it and when is the end result
of this well we're already seeing a
profound impact on healthcare we've
barely scratched the surface of what
genomic research can actually yield but
it's already having a significant impact
in 2018 around one-third of new
fda-approved drugs actually relied on
genomics and interesting enough in 2005
Francis Collins the director of national
of the National Human Genome Research
Institute predicted that most drugs by
2020 would be derived or used using the
understanding of the human genome and
we're actually not that far from it and
another interesting fact is by this year
the expectation in 2020 the expectation
that we'll be around 26 million people
while shared their DNA with one of the
four leading commercial ancestry forms
so this is actually becoming a trend
another interesting trend is what we
call as a rise of genomic bio bags it's
quite interesting
while iBanking is sort of the result of
advances in human genome in computing
and bioinformatics and if you
think of it it's really a modern way of
storing managing and analyzing massive
amounts of biological data many
population-based bio banks have been
formed in different countries and is
actually becoming a central national
strategy some examples include the UK
biobank the Fijian project in Finland
and the biobank grass in Austria and why
banking is actually quite important
because they act as a central hub for
other organizations such as farmers
universities research institutes and
they provide a way for these Institute's
or organisations to access data to
conduct research there are strategic
very strategic because they help the
industry overall and format form as an
accelerator for research yet they still
face very common challenges so let's
talk a bit about that some because of
because sequencing has become a lot more
prevalent and cheaper
we're just generally getting a huge
increase in genomic data and this rapid
growth is really in petabytes of data
and that means when you're actually
needing to share that data among other
organizations you're talking about an
exabyte level of sharing this large
growth of data together with the
complexity of having to analyze a lot of
this data requires a new scale of
compute and storage and when we talking
new scale we're not talking a few
hundred or thousands VMs like in many
cases or that we've seen you need
something like a hundred thousand cores
to be able to do one process over from a
result of a sequencing activity most
organizations don't have that scale or
resource and in many cases they need to
be able to do it in a bursty way such
that they suddenly receive a large data
dump and they need to process it in a
very short period of time
what's happening because of this is that
technology is actually becoming the
limiter of research because many
organizations are not set up to be able
to handle this love
of compute so how does cloud actually
help solve this problem well if you
start by looking at the traditional way
in which things worked and when you see
a traditional we mean this is how
biobanks research institutes and farmers
all are set up to work today
this is the environment and process that
they have when the volumes of data are
small and the requirements were actually
quite different and how that works is
that all the data is centralized and in
a repository and whenever any researcher
or organization wants to conduct
research on that data they basically
make a copy and use it on their own
workstation or compute cluster where
effectively data sharing meant data
copying so if you think about it how is
this practical when you have been a
bicep data how do you actually manage to
process all that data if you're talking
about petabytes of data this requires
considerable compute and many of these
organizations have what effectively is
is fixed compute and they only Hardware
and they don't have the ability to scale
200,000 cores to be able to process that
data and with many scientists they would
have to wait in a queue because a
specific organization would only have
one compute cluster and for different
Sciences to be able to conduct work they
have to wait until the other ones are
done and another challenge that this
actually poses is security
implementation because the way that data
is shared each time it's shared in a
different way and copied that means you
need to put specific city a specific
custom security control mechanism for
each activity for each sharing of data
and that actually makes it quite
vulnerable because you're not you don't
have a comprehensive overarching
security methodology so how does public
cloud actually change this model well in
in public cloud all the data and compute
would be centralized and the researchers
and institutions would go to that data
add compute so they would only be
copy of the data maintained and how we
actually have access to that data will
be controlled is using things like I am
and identity access management where
each each organization or individual
that needs to access that data is
controlled the access is controlled at a
very granular level such that the only
access to the data they need and only
perform the actions they need to for the
benefit of the research and at the same
time because it's cloud-based it
provides an elastic level of compute and
storage such that if they suddenly need
to do high-level processing with a
hundred thousand course they have access
to that and it's elastic in the sense
that they don't need to preserve that or
reserve that compute power beforehand
they use it when they need it and they
only use it while they need it and this
also gives a benefit of having a
centralized security implementation such
that the way to control security here is
to provide access to individuals or
organizations in a very controlled way
and you would have a comprehensive
security method implemented so we talked
quite a bit about some of the thule
that's available and in terms of like
what cloud can provide in terms of high
level compute and storage and the
benefits of that next we're going to be
talking about specific tooling that is
custom-made for a genomic data that can
be either deployed or natively available
on GCP until you happen to talk about
that thank you I think there are many
tools that are available to
bioinformaticians trying to use GCP for
genomics analysis so let's have a look
at some of these tools Hale is one of
the common tools that provide powerful
data science tools that can be used to
interrogate large-scale data Hale uses
spark in Hadoop which means it can be
deployed on top of data proc which is
our managed Hadoop service and Hale
actually has native support for data
Prague and we will see more of this
later pipelines
on top of workflow management engines
are also among the common tools many
bioinformaticians use we have built the
life sciences API to make it easy for
these workflow engines to integrate with
Google clouds and be able to run at
cloud scale some examples of the
workflow engines that take advantage of
the life sciences API are Cromwell which
is developed by the Broad Institute next
flow and Snape make are two other
workflow engines that are open-source
and are very popular in the community
these workflow engines are commonly used
by by banks and research organizations
to process and analyze thousands of
whole genome sequences with ease but
working with common file formats for
genomics and variant data can be
challenging when working with machine
learning frameworks which was one of the
drivers of developing the variants
transform tool the variant transform
tool is an open-source tool developed by
Google cloud and now has many
contributors from the community it can
export variants data to bigquery this
makes it easy to interrogate the data
using SQL statements in a very fast and
efficient way it also makes it quite
easy to build datasets that can be
consumed easily by machine learning
frameworks or our AI platform to build
new machine learning models but
sometimes all the researchers want is to
simply access row compute power it could
be that they need a machine with more
than a hundred course or even terabytes
of memory to run something like a de
novo Gina sembly or use an HPC cluster
such as a slurm or any number of the
tools that they can run on top of Google
compute engine such as galaxy or toil
which can actually use the compute
engine API to provision instances many
of the bioinformaticians may also be
using research analysis platform such as
tera which was developed by verily which
is an alphabet company also by the Broad
Institute to enable researchers to
collaborate on workspaces share
notebooks and easily launch pipelines
through Cromwell integrations this makes
such analysis platforms a one-stop-shop
to access datasets and be able to run
your analysis and share that and
collaborate with others
and of course there are many more tools
from the community and our partner
ecosystems that can be added to this
toolbox for bioinformaticians so let us
look at Hale in a more bit of details as
I mentioned before Hale runs on top of
data block and data block enables you
not just to create a dupe cluster in
seconds but also enables you to easily
scale up and down this cluster this
flexibility is one of the key advantages
of running Hale on Google Cloud you can
easily create a small cluster with just
a couple of worker nodes to configure
debug and test your code and once you
are ready to run your large G Waze
analysis or large variant calling
analysis you can easily scale up to
hundreds or even thousands of nodes and
you can also add preemptable instances
which can help speed up execution and
keep the costs down once you are done
you can scale down or simply delete that
cluster as it it only takes you a couple
of minutes to provision really a new one
there is no more waiting in a queue for
the local clustered or being limited by
the on-prem capacity the data proc
integration is now part of the core Hale
library you can create a Hale cluster
from the cloud shell in just a couple of
minutes with just these two lines you
see in the screen it is insanely easy if
you have attempted to deploy a Hadoop or
SPARC lustre before and configure an
install software and its workers you
would know that it can take days and you
may still not not be able to achieve the
performance and scale you would get from
running on cloud
many of the existing tools use common
genomics format such as fast cube amps
prams VCFs etc but building datasets
out of these file formats or
cross-examining with other data coming
from healthcare systems imaging or even
jail or weather data can be really
challenging the variants transform is an
open-source tool that uses data flow to
export your variant data to bigquery on
a standard schema the use of data flow
allows you to scale if you have a large
data set as this could otherwise be a
very time-consuming process
big query requires zero management and
allows you to store and query petabytes
of data in minutes sometimes even
seconds without the hassle of managing
any infrastructure and only paying for
the queries you execute there is already
lots of public genomics data sets that
you can explore today on the queries
such as the 1000 genome platinum genomes
or the public accent portion a public
access portion of the TCGA there is also
multiple non-human variant data such as
the genomics cannabis or the rice 3k
which has variants that are called using
deep variants the other key advantage to
having the data in bigquery is how easy
it is to create cohorts and datasets
that can be used in sensor flow or other
machine learning frameworks easily and
and you can take advantage of they are
platform tools such as they are
notebooks to interact with your variant
data using Python or are very easily so
color is one of our customers who did
just that there is a very interesting
blog post on our website on how they
used variants transform and bigquery to
create machine learning models that beat
standard industry models in just weeks
so one of the reasons many have chosen
Google cloud for the genomics workloads
is that we don't just provide
infrastructure our product and
engineering teams have developed a
number of services and api's that cater
to the needs of healthcare and life
sciences community such as the
healthcare API that supports health
records in fire and hl7 format or the
imaging API to interact with DICOM the
life sciences API was developed to
enable workflow engines to take
advantage of Google Cloud in large scale
this is a reference architecture for
running workflows at scale and GCP raw
data from sequencers or other sources
typically would be uploaded to Google
Cloud storage and the workflow engine
would drawn on a Google compute engine
or in your own infrastructure or machine
and then would make rest calls to the
life sciences API the life sciences API
takes care of the full lifecycle of each
step in the pipeline from creating a
virtual machine with exactly the number
of cores
memories specified localizing the input
files and copying them from storage
pulling docker images and running that
step then the localizing the output
again to the cloud storage and it is
able to do that in scale the Broad
Institute for example have used the API
to call variants for all 79,000 whole
genome sequences in the nomad dataset in
just three days
several workflow engines or batch job
managers like d-sub taking advantage of
the Life Sciences API this includes
chromel as we said before which was
developed by the Broad next flow which
we will see later in the demo and snake
make which is a recent additions all
these workflow engine have very active
user community and with many standard
and sample pipelines in github that you
can easily run the life sciences API
makes it easy for the developers of
these workflow engines to build quickly
on top of Google Cloud and also include
tools that allows you to debug your
pipeline or generate data that can be
used to analyze your pipeline calculate
the compute cost of a pipeline or a
particular step in the pipeline on the
right hand side this is what a typical
pipeline might look like it's a pretty a
series of tasks that may include
scattering across multiple processes or
gathering and collating them for each
step the API will create a virtual
machine once the step is completed the
virtual machine is deleted this helps
keep the cost of the pipeline down as
you don't have to pay for a cluster and
standing all the time and you don't have
to pay for any idle instances now let us
run a sample pipeline on Google Cloud
using next flow this is a sample
configuration for a profile to run with
Google life's life sciences executor you
will notice I have specified the region
I want my compute instances to be and
the bucket used for temporary and
intermediate files I have also selected
which region the Life Sciences API will
sort the metadata about the execution of
the pipeline and finally I said the use
private addresses to true as I already
have an add gateway set up in the
project and I don't want to use public
IPS for added security now let's switch
to my virtual machine
so now I'm going to run a test pipeline
I wrote on my virtual machine to install
and run next flow I need to set some
environmental variables I've already
done that in my bash I see to save time
every time I'm using this so as you can
see I've added the the key to my service
account the version I want to run and
Google as an execution mode so now I'm
going to run the pipeline I'm going to
pass in a config file which has all my
configurations and project information
and I'm going to run my test pipeline
which just compares the performance of
GPU versus CPU
I'm going to select the Google life
sciences profile and I'm going to add
some options to actually be able to
debug and monitor the performance of my
pipeline so as you can see the pipeline
is now running it will automatically
create a virtual machine on Google Cloud
to see that on tower I can see that now
my workflow is running I can check on
the resources and the virtual machine
that it's using and I can actually
monitor deep while it's being executed
spoiler alerts the GPU beats the CPU in
this one I can also check previous
pipelines that I've ran before with
Tower I can check the CPU usage so I can
actually optimize my pipeline and select
the correct virtual machine shape I can
check memory execution time and so on
it's actually very helpful when
troubleshooting and actually optimizing
your pipelines for cloud so that was our
demo I hope you enjoyed it as much as I
did thank you very much for your time of
course there are many more tools out
there that are from our partners and
ecosystems and if you have any questions
please share them with us on the dory
thank you everyone for the opportunity
to present to you today it was very
exciting for us we look forward to
seeing your questions on the dory
thank you